this is such a wonderful new step in my
life and I'm still getting used to it
because it's obviously been a whirlwind
but I haven't seen myself happier and
just being in the whole situation of
finding somebody who can be a partner to
you in so many ways than one
is amazing so I guess I'm very excited
mr. and mrs. Jonas have arrived yup guys
Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra stepped
out as an official married couple look
at them we love it the string of iconic
fashion moments continue here they are
officially married on Monday after
weekend of festivities and celebrations
and parties oh my god so much going on
how did you celebrate Nick and
Priyanka's wedding weekend ah with some
wine and for all those Jonas brother
girls that love Nick Jonas I'm sure they
were doing this a little bit of morning
I was also having some champagne trying
to get married twice like Priyanka but I
wasn't able to Priyanka is wearing a
beautiful teal sari white shades and a
traditional sindoor that's the red hair
part usually worn by married women and
the always fashionable Nick is given a
thumbs up in his all time sambal
probably cuz he's married to Priyanka
Chopra and look at that he's got his
wedding band on display they are so
proud and married it's this happily ever
after we've all been waiting for this
couple has been so captivating why do
you think that they are such an
interesting couple to everybody I feel
like people love their dynamic because
it was unexpected like we didn't see
Priyanka and Nick coming together but
something about maybe their
personalities and just their love for
each other glows that's what I like and
I think a lot of times in in celeb
culture we see these people get together
and it's a whirlwind and we're kind of
like they're gonna break up but the two
I'm like no these this is like true love
that we are watching and we get to see
it it does exist of course we know the
two became engaged in August after a few
months of dating they had not one but
two weddings over the weekend in India
that's why I said married twice yeah
they had a Christian ceremony officiated
by Nick's father on Saturday followed by
a traditional Hindu ceremony on Sunday
and it looked like the party we were
missing out on like I had extreme FOMO
God his Priyanka crammed like a lifetime
of iconic fashion moments into a single
weekend my favorite look was the
multicolored
red and yellow ensemble she was just
floating it felt like he had the picture
where she was just like flowing like a
goddess
I loved the gold ensemble that she
worked her Sangeet ceremony
gorgeous gorgeous of course I'm gonna
know all across social your favorite
fashion moment of the weekend we have
ours let's know what yours are and I
want to know if they're done celebrating
their nuptials do you think they're
gonna have some kind of stateside
ceremony for maybe family members and
friends that couldn't attend and we know
they love to party so I'm thinking yes
and we love watching them party I can
definitely imagine more it's gonna
happen stateside I want to see where
their honeymoon destination is going
yeah because those photos are going to
be steamy burning up thank you for
sharing Priyanka Nick
honestly like they're just sharing their
whole love with us and I love it we love
it of course if you want to see the
whole breakdown of the festivities we
have it over on e t online.com a full
deep dive deeper let's keep talking
across social I met Courtney underscore
tether know and I'm at ash Crossin until
next time we've got you covered